- What do we have here?
We have two new colors.
We've got the new Mystic
Red, and Mystic White.
The Samsung Galaxy Z Flip was...
Is my favorite phone of 2020.
That's not to say that I
didn't love the Fold too,
but there's just
something about this phone
that just felt incredible,
being able to flip that thing
open, it was just really cool.
Look at that box, oh, so cool.
I was actually just reminiscing
about when I got the original Z Flip.
We went to the mall.
We went all the way to Glendale,
which is not actually that far,
but when you live in the
west side of Los Angeles,
you might as well just charter
a helicopter at that point.
But I went and met John
at the Samsung store
because he had ordered two of these.
So then I went and bought it off of him,
and went to the mall.
That was a really fun video.
That was right before lockdown.
(gasps)
I'm so excited to see
this, I'm so excited.
It's so freaking fresh.
I don't even know what to say.
This is the perfect color.
It's a matte finish as well.
Look at that. Holy
crap, this is beautiful.
Oh my goodness. I'm
smudging it up already.
(ethereal music)
Oh my god.
Look at this!
Just beautiful, iridescent, mystic white!
Let's see what else is in here.
Charger, cable.
I mean, this is gonna kinda
be a really quick video
because you've already seen
reviews of both of these phones
on mine and everyone's channels.
There's really not much
else to say about it.
Do you wanna get a closer
look? Yeah, get in there.
(upbeat hip-hop music)
Even the little hinge has
sort of an iridescent color.
I guess a little shade
of purple and a pink.
Just enough to give it sort of that opal,
kind of iridescent look.
So now let's check out the red Note 25G.
Take a look at this.
Wow.
I'm not a huge fan of the color red,
but when it is on these types of devices
with this kind of matte
frosted glass back,
it just really gives these
phones a whole other look.
It gives it sort of a
dimensional type look.
Look at that, wow, get closer,
get closer, get closer.
(upbeat hip-hop music)
Okay, let's look at
both of these together.
Yeah, don't those look great?
So I know this is kind of a short video,
but I really wanted to
show these to you guys
because I really do
love when they bring out
different colors and different variations,
and I feel like the more
videos and more content
that you see these in
actual people's hands,
the better that you're able to judge
what the color would actually look like
when you get it in person.
So this is it, this is
what they look like.
I really, really...
I really love this red.
I'm wondering from you guys, though,
what is your favorite phone
that was released in 2020?
Also, what is your favorite color phone
Even if that's not your
favorite phone from this year,
you can still say that you like the color.
Also, what do you guys think about these?
Do you like the red, do
you like the mystic white?
Because clearly we all know I'm obsessed.
I'll see you guys in my next video.
Bye!
(upbeat hip-hop music)